the trust.
Start talking before it's but touching time in jail. You a weirdo
gank some girls for no reason. >> Yeah, I don't know if
like there's a police. Maybe it's like that most of his class
watches him on YouTube. He's got a VP on while admitting to it
on stream. You got You just love to see it. Okay. They'll never
catch me. I've got a VPN on, guys. They'll never They'll never
figure it out. concerned that maybe this guy was showing real
signs that he was going to hurt somebody and the cops kept sweeping
under the rug because of some connection. Like that's that's
what I'm more concerned about. Well, sorry. That's Yeah, he's
guilty. So, that's what I'd be most concerned about right now
is is basically like was this guy a ticking time bomb that they
ignored because he has family connections at the top of the police
departments in these
Teen suspects eerie remarks about hit-and- run deaths of New
Jersey girls and disturbing live stream. More of the story. Teen
driver charged with intentionally mowing down two 17-year-old
girls in New Jersey, including one he was allegedly stalking,
ranted about the horrific crash in a chilling video a day before
his arrest as the victim's families claimed the sickening attack
was planned for months. This dude literally ran two girls over
and then went live. Okay, he went live to play like MLB 2K or
some baseball game.
And I think I got I think I I think the full stream is still
up. So this guy this guy was stalking this girl. He ran that
girl and her friend down with his car and then he went home.
His his dad's a cop apparently, but we'll we'll get to that in
just a second. Okay.
Then he went home
and he went live. He actually just went live.
>> My best friend you animal. >> I don't know if
I want to uh I don't know if I want to cover all I don't I want
to read more of the article cuz I want to go through and listen
to the video. Okay. But suffice to say, all you need to know
is this guy's just within the past 24 hours, I believe. Right.
September 30th was when he did it. Yesterday was No, no, no.
Yeah. Within within the past 24 hours, he had just run those
two girls over. All right. And then he opens this up to play
some
>> You animal. >> Wait, what did that say? >> My
best friend you animal.
>> You my best friend, you animal,
bro. That might be actually sincere. Like that could actually
be from like a high school friend who is messaging him via Xbox
Live or whatever he's playing this on. Well, he's his chat's
apparently like coming through automatically. Oh, wait. That
sorry. Yeah, that might be if this is on a console that might
be through Xbox Live or something. I don't know if that's his
uh chat or what. >> I don't need negativity in this stream.
>> Dude, that's that's nuts.
That's nuts. Right. Listen, he's he sits down to open up fire
up a couple games of baseball or whatever the this game is. I
don't know. He fire up a couple, you know, play a couple innings,
just kill some people, and somebody goes, "You my best friend."
You go, "You know what? I don't need I don't need the negativity,
guys. Can you just keep the comments positive?" All right. Clean
up the chat.
Mods,
ban that guy. Mods. Mods. Mods. Ban that guy. and that guy right
now. >> I don't need negativity in this stream.
>> So, everybody's getting timed out. So,
I'll explain what happened, but I'm not going to do it with people.
>> Two girls. >> Okay. You know what? Now, I'm really
thinking if I should really do this. >> I don't need >> Dude,
you them two girls. I don't need negativity, buddy. You ran over
two
>> Negativity, buddy. You ran over two girls. I tried to
explain
several things, but I got like 50 different people messaging
negativity, which is something I don't need, and neither does
my friend. >> Guys, can't you just show a little empathy
for the murderer?
Why does nobody care? Murderers are victims, too, in their own
way. Okay? Why can't you guys understand that >> everybody's
getting timed out? It's a timeout chain. I'll get to the point
if people stop flooding my chat. All right? So, I'm going to
get I'm going to explain what happens and
>> Oh, did you see my donut? I have donos muted. Uh, I
will do donos after this segment. I'll go through I'll do all
the donos after this segment. Uh, yeah, I have donos muted right
now. >> I'm going to do this very quickly because we we
have just one game to play
>> here. I'll actually real quick.
I'll go find the I'll go find the Reban Ruben dono and do that
real quick. And then right after the Reban Rubin no I'm I'm keeping
them muted and then I'll unmute and I'll go through all of them
after a little bit. Now I understand with Reben Rubin specifically
that might be a bit of a problem. Oh >> Donated $3.
>> Is he hoping for a no hitter with this >> I didn't
see it. I literally didn't see it before I replayed it. Damn.
Thank you, Reuben Ruben. I don't know if I could if I could just
get Reben Rubin chats alone to come through TTS automatically.
I would do that. I don't know how to set that up, but we'll see.
Okay, we'll see. I'm going back to muting alerts here. >> And
everybody's getting timed out. >> 131 viewers. I Where
are you seeing that? He's got 131 viewers. I actually don't see
that on the screen here. >> I don't need my chat flooded.
All right. I'm I'm going to wait until
>> pops up sometimes. Oh, 151. >> I'm not I'm not
going to do this with a flooded chat. I got 111 people in here.
>> You are an inspiration.
A-Rod, I apologize, but this stream ain't going to start anytime
soon if people keep messaging negativity. >> Why are we
running people over? >> Everybody's messaging negativity.
It's
>> Negativity, guys. Just just a bunch of negative Nellies.
What? I I do a hit and run on two women and and now suddenly
everybody's got a problem with running down women. Is it just
because of me? Is it only me? Listen, nobody went after Chris.
Uh, wait, Chris Jenner? What? Why can't I think of the female
name? Bruce Jenner. Bruce Jenner. And went to
whatever. [__] me, man. Missed it. Missed it. Missed
my timing. Nobody cares about Bruce Jenner running Caitlyn Jenner
running those people down. Okay, >> they only care about
this guy doing it. >> I'll explain it in a minute if people
stop messaging negativity.
Yo, bro. >> Dude. Dude. >> Yo. Yo. Yo. Chill, guys.
Hi. >> This guy's really regretting
really
doing the TTS for every message option right now. Okay, >> it's
funny that Let me explain something real quick before I get the
stream going.
The more you guys engage in the chat, the more you give me engagement
and I get paid for YouTube. >> I'm not one of them. >> Just
letting you all know. >> Hi,
stream after incident. check mark
>> This is actually you guys are making good points. I
don't know. Can somebody try to figure out how all the chatters
knew that this happened before he actually talked about it on
the stream cuz he must have tweeted it or it must have gone like
big somewhere, right? There's got to be something about it. >> Are
you going to jail? >> That's fine. That's fine. Y'all are
just giving me engagement. That's fine. That's fine. >> Can
you say hi Sam? You seen this?
>> Stream the trial. >> You seeing this? >> How
you going to get paid in jail? >> This is absurd. >> Connor
he is chopped. >> Jesus Christ. Do you all have a life?
>> Unfortunately, it's not AI. >> What are you doing?
>> And again, I'll explain it. This is
This is actually ridiculous. >> Say hi to Dam
Sam.
>> Not doing until people stop messaging negativity.
Can you say hi to Sam? >> I wonder if at any point he's
going to actually talk about what happened or if he's just going
to complain about the chat and the negativity the entire time
and then eventually log off because it does not go very long
this stream. >> Joey bro
yo Joey Quasono chopped ass [__] 34 people watching
this. It's actually ridiculous. >> Thoughts on a pack.
>> All right. >> Mason Anel gets with Fro. >> Now
that the dust has settled, I'm going to explain what happened.
Keep making fake accounts. Just keep doing it. I mean, >> did
you get bail money?
RIP Isabelle and Maria, you monster. RIP Isabelle Maria, you
monster. >> RIP Isabelle and Maria, you monster. >> Jail
Street. >> It's called being detained, not bailed >> RIP
Isabelle and Maria, you monster. >> Now, I at some point
we'll pause and we'll talk about like the
Do we have to talk about like the society that that creates somebody
like this? Do we have to talk about that? Cuz like how in the
world does this guy feel comfortable being like, "Yeah, I just
uh yeah, I just murdered two people. I'm going to go live and
then I'm going to be outraged. I'm going to be outraged that
people bring it up, right?" Like, what happened? How does How
does this person
>> Rip Isabelle and Maria, you monster. RIP Isabelle and
Maria. >> I may not even start this. I'm not going to lie.
>> Run at 2K RQ. >> I may not start this. I may not
do this >> Pain in my broken heart. I may not even do this.
>> No. Started [__] >> Don't listen to
the haters.
Guys, stop. We need an explanation.
>> You hold just giving me engagement. You guys are so
dumb. >> You guys are just making me way more popular on
YouTube. Okay, you guys are just Don't you guys know you're just
helping me? You're helping me be way more popular on YouTube
right now. That's what's going on here. Don't you guys understand?
Stop making me popular. Stop making this more popular. >> Explain,
bro.
Please start. I want to see MLB
He's just going to incriminate himself.
I like 2K. >> I didn't start a stream.
>> It's a little similar except I just mute these people
on the stream and like I don't see their chats. I let them say
whatever they want. >> All right. Are are we done? >> Good
times.
>> Going like the victim. >> No, we're not. No, we're
not. No, we're not done. We're not Oh, lord. Oh, lord. >> Dude,
people are just people are just going to roast him. Pain in your
broken
>> Did you end the stream? >> Same kid who hit the
two girls. >> No, but I might not even start it. I'm going
to give this until 10:30. If people keep flooding my chat, I'm
ending the stream. >> Bro, stop selling.
Let him start it. Bro, start it. Trust.
Start talking before it's but touching time in jail. You a weirdo.
Gank some girls for no >> Yeah. I don't know if like there's
a police maybe it's like that most of his class watches him on
YouTube and people are like starting to pick up this stream who
are in his class or in his like school and that's like all the
people posting.
I don't know. I I do want to know exactly like how and we'll
we'll try to figure it out shortly after how they all knew that
this happened. >> Bro, y'all selling
so do >> I don't play Fortnite. You idiot. >> Log
two girls gone buddy.
You're such a weirdo. You can rot.
I'm coming for your head, boy.
Police ain't Yoshi up yet. He's milking views. Loudly crying
face. >> You know what? I have an idea. >> I know
how we're going to fix this. >> Like, just don't be live
when you're accused of running down a girl you've been stalking.
>> Can we start? >> Did we really just make a fake
name of me just to
>> I'm thinking I'm thinking maybe another way to kill
>> Killer. Killer. >> Okay. He used to have a public
Tik Tok. It looks like used to have a public Tik Tok.
I don't know if anybody would have saved the stuff from this
Tik Tok before [__] popped off. Okay, but people
are saying someone in chat just said maybe this is how they actually
found this guy in the first place. Maybe he had like more of
a following on Tik Tok or >> They're going to put you in
a cell with Diddy.
No, that's my name.
This boa bugen.
Someone brick his window while his live loudly crying face.
Roth.
No, that's my name, bro. Yo, what's up, Vinnie?
Cold face.
Bro's chopped.
Yo, >> dude. Evan just Evan's just chilling. Okay, Evan.
He's just relaxed. He's just having a good time. He's just He's
there to play some What was this called? What was this called?
It wasn't called Game Day. What was the What was the name of
the the game? It like flashed up here for a second. Road show.
The The show. The show. Okay. The show 25. >> You're going
to jail MF. Just start. >> Oh, the show 25. There we go.
There we >> You know what? Good point. I may turn >> Wait,
if it's the show 25 and it's like um and it's it's got the MLB
logo, does that mean it's EA Sports? Did they did they rename
Did they try to make everything like Madden where they have their
own names that aren't just like MLB 2025 or something? Turn off
the chat. How do I do that?
>> Live chat is off.
>> Oh, come on. >> Thank you for somebody to remind
me of >> dude. What a >> There's now no more live
chat cuz none of you know how to how to act. All right. Now,
now that I got that figured out, I'm going to finally explain
this whole situation. >> Oh, Sony's the publisher. Okay.
>> And I'm not >> he's going to explain exactly why
it's not weird for him to be online right >> Authorized
to talk about the whole thing. So, I'm going to do this in five
minutes right now.
>> Ah, where have I heard this before? Guys, I want to
go live and talk about my legal troubles, but I'm not authorized
to talk about much of it. So, I'm just going to paint you a story.
Okay. about me and Evan, >> many such cases >> played
co-op since well not co-op but we've streamed MLB since 2020
and we made a lot of memories in the past
and
it has been a a fun long ride but I need to explain some things
that have happened over the past few days and I'm not going to
talk much about it but in a neighboring town unfortunately
Two girls were in a
hit and run crash.
>> h well, he's he's done a good job. He hasn't incriminated
himself yet and he's been talking for 4 seconds. Surely this
will continue to go well. >> There has been a lot of misinformation
going on over the internet.
But I will say this. I wish my sincerest
to those two girls lost in that tragic accident.
Okay. >> Wait, why do you think it's an accident? Who Who's
calling it an accident? It's It's almost like you were there.
The >> It is an absolute unfortunate situation.
And there's more to the story that you're not getting. But when
the time
I will explain it in greater detail. I'm not authorized to talk
about the old thing. I'm not going to give you any more information.
But I will say this,
Not everything is as it seems. Listen, come back to me like a
year from now, guys, when I'm totally not in jail and I'll tell
you all about what actually happened here, okay? Once once the
shackles are off and I can say
All right? Then guys, then I'll come and tell you and then it'll
all make sense. >> Making threats
against my family will not be tolerated. My cousin has received
hateful messages over social media
about this whole spiel and he's had to unfollow me on everything
because of this whole drama. Why are you guys getting him involved?
>> Dude, the the vehicular manslaughter drama goes crazy.
The vehicular manslaughter drama is
crazy,
chat. You have no idea. >> It's one thing. Okay,
if you hate me, you hate me. If you don't, you don't. You're
opening up Pandora's box, getting family involved,
and that just does not sit right with me. So, I figured I'd
make a statement about what happened. And I want to address something
else. Okay. By the way, if you had no context and if the chat
was off the whole time, so the chatters hadn't been saying, "Yeah,
you killed you killed two people. Like, you you're going to rot
or whatever." Right? If people hadn't been doing that, he still
hasn't like said that he's involved at all. He hasn't said, "I'm
I'm like accused." He said nothing. You'd have no idea what he's
talking about if you just looked at what he's saying here in
a vacuum. So, he's like, "I wanted to make a statement about
what happened." It's like, "Yeah, so people got killed in another
town." totally
>> because this is a very serious incident that happens.
And I really don't even know if I should be streaming this right
now, but
no, you shouldn't. You should be offline. You should be you should
ask your lawyers. Okay? Any public communications that you're
going to do while you have a pending criminal or I assume like
civil case, that should run through your lawyers. You shouldn't
be speaking publicly, especially on the matters at hand.
It will only hurt you. It cannot help you. It will only hurt
you.
At least in terms of the legality may I don't know, man.
I
I have built a great following on Tik Tok with 39,000 followers
that I have grown since 2020.
And I want to thank each and every single one of y'all. I love
you all to absolute death.
of what happens, if you don't see me streaming
for a little bit, you'll understand why. But this will be this
will be in the hands of Jesus. Everything will be okay. I will
get this sorted out. And I plan to keep continuing playing co-op
with my best friend, Evan. He has stuck by me through the whole
side, and I want to thank him for that. Without my loyal friend,
>> dude. Evan's just like Evan's sitting there. He's like,
"Hey, could you stop mentioning my name? Could you like He's
like typing, okay, over over Discord. Could you stop mentioning
my name? Please stop talking about me, okay? I'm here. I just
want to play the show, bro. You didn't even tell me you're going
to stream. Can you chill? Can you chill, dog?" Evan's Evan's
going to get thrown off the uh off the under the bus. Okay. Evan's
going to get thrown under the bus. This guy's [__]
over >> playing out with me. I wouldn't be streaming YouTube
right now.
So,
>> oh, never mind. >> There's more to the story.
Listen, Evan's just trying to help the cops. Never mind. He wouldn't
he wouldn't even be streaming right now if it weren't for Evan.
Okay, Evan was like, "Hey, man. Why don't you fire up why don't
you fire up the stream for old time sake? Fire up the stream.
Get one more going." Okay,
come on. >> But again, I'm not going to be surprised to
comment. And I want to thank each and every single
one of you guys
that have stuck by me >> through this whole thing. And
I want to I want to address one more thing. Okay. >> I
don't know how many people stuck by him. It seems like he had
to shut his chat off because they weren't sticking by him. >> I
really think there needs to be more done to address
mental health
in this state. Cuz >> bruh bruh what?
I I Here's the thing. That might be true. Okay, that might be
true. But he is going to be talking about the people responding
to him on his live chat and like the people who are saying that
he killed those two girls and he's a monster. That's what he
actually means when he says mental health needs to be addressed.
No, no, no. I don't even I don't know if he's working on a mental
health or like an insanity defense. I don't think so.
We'll we'll see. Maybe I'm Maybe I'm misunderstanding. I feel
like he's going to talk about the people who are like trying
to bring him down right now. Let's see who has the better read.
mental health
in the state because you know I don't even know how to explain
this dude. I've been bullied, ridiculed and stuff over false
allegations. Okay, >> told you. Called it. Called it. Called
it. Called it. Called it. Called it. Called it. I told you. I
could see. I could see it 100%. He's not saying I'm insane. He's
just saying I guys insane people going after me, man. It's only
insane people going after me. That's it. over this whole thing
about things that have happened in the past. There's more to
this story.
It'll come out in the future. Okay? And I'm going to let you
all know this right now. I don't plan to go anywhere anytime
soon regarding streaming,
but
Jay-to look at himself one month after he killed me. No,
no, dude. This guy's way too a I this don't compare me to this
guy. Don't compare me to this >> Again, if I do end up
taking a hiatus,
I'm telling you guys why the I really think New Jersey needs
to do a better job addressing this mental health crisis because
I've been through way too much. I'm a nice kid. I'm 17 years
old. Hold on. Don't hold my past against me. Murdered people
a couple days ago. He didn't murder people a couple days ago.
I believe he might have uh unless I'm misunderstanding. I thought
he murdered these people on the 30th. Maybe. Hold on. We'll have
to get the a clear timeline. Okay. Accused of striking them around
5:30 p.m. I believe on the 30th of September. So I pair were
airlifted to a hospital where they died and then I believe he
went live like right after that if I'm not mistaken. Check. The
stream date is the 30th but I thought he did this on the 30th
as well. Let's see if we can find this here. Connected to charged
with murder after hit and run.
Hold on. Striking two New Jersey teen girls. This is on October
1st. On Wednesday, authorities said
UCPO. Hold on. Let me let me go back to this. Let me go to this.
What? Oh, hold on. No, it was it was on Oh, September 29th, next
day then. So, this is the day after within 24 hours, basically.
September 29th is when he struck them. September 30th is when
he does the stream with a good family by my side.
And these allegations that have been ruining
everything is a shame. But again, I'm going to leave it at that.
I really think you all should
be a lot nicer to each other. If anything happens, I'm going
to give you all some advice. All right? If you get bullied and
ridiculed in school about, you know, stuff that people hate you,
I would
tell your counselor immediately and you know, before this gets
out of hand,
you got to >> Okay, now I think he's talking about himself.
Now I think he's trying to imply some happened with him and he
was like defending I think that's what he's trying to do now
and this is not a good look
stuff that people hate you. I'm going to give you all some advice.
>> Well that's why that's why I'm here bro the show that's
just in the background. All right I'm here to listen to to Vinnie
and Evan the while they play the show. All right. Thank you Vinnie.
I need the evidence or I I need the advice. If you get bullied
and ridiculed in school about, you know, stuff that people hate
you, I would
tell your counselor immediately. And, you know, before this gets
out of hand,
you got to address all the things cuz I'll tell you what, the
amount of bullying that I've been put through in the past has
been
absurd. And I'm going to be honest with you, the state is not
doing a right job addressing this mental health crisis. And I
hope Shidarelli can fix this.
>> Is that the governor or something? So that is all I'm
going to say about this whole thing. I'm not going to talk about
it anymore on the advice of
loved ones and others.
We're going to play co-op with Evan and we're only going to do
one game and depending upon
the next steps. I'll probably be live tomorrow
because here's the thing. I was originally going to start a school
today, but with all this hurrah happening,
it kind of screwed that up. So, I plan to be live tomorrow. I
don't know about Evan, but >> Evan is like trying to cut
bait already. Evan is in the DMs trying to cut bait right now
actively. >> Again, you're going to be seeing more lives
coming in the future
>> and I will address this whole thing hopefully in the
next coming days.
>> So, Evan, if you want to say anything, you are more
than welcome to. You don't want to >> No way. >> Anything
else? >> Evan, you there? Oh, Evan's voice is low. You
can't hear Evan. I thought I thought Evan dipped. I thought Evan
dipped.
It sounds like It sounds like his voice is low. >> It's
very sad. Say that again. That is our goal for the future. Again,
we've been live for the past 5 years. We've developed a very
good relationship,
a very good friendship,
and I plan to keep doing this as long as I can. As a huge baseball
fan, I want to entertain you guys. I love gaming so much. This
is my safe spot, gaming. If I wasn't doing this right now, I
don't know what I'd be doing.
But there was something else. I think there was something else
I was going to say. Yeah. So,
we're going to play co-op with Evan
and we're going to get into a 2v2
and I hope to make you all happy this stream
and
I hope you all enjoy. We're at current rating of six. You know
what? Here, hang on. >> I I'm just curious how they end
up ending the stream now. like how does it it ends in like two
minutes. How is it going to end? >> I'm gonna do something
real quick. So, that is what I had to address and we're done.
So, let me uh let me do this real
>> Didn't he get doxed? I don't know if he got doxed. I
think he just had his name on his stuff. Like I think his TikTok
has the same name on it. So,
Or are you saying like his address got posted or >> wait,
wait.
This you just realized. Okay. like 90 missed calls from uh from
his like dad and his lawyer being like, "Get off the get off
the computer. Get off the stream."
>> Uh, no. I want to display. But there was something else
I wanted to Wait, did I get rid of the whole thing? >> Yeah,
you got rid of the You got rid of the whole thing. I can't see
your face anymore, man. What are you doing? >> Oh, whoops.
>> Okay, well, I'll do this. >> I wanted to make
that video separate for the statement. So, what I'm going to
do >> Oh, he's going to end the stream and start a new
stream. >> I'm going to go live again and I'm going to
restart the stream back up and you all will see some good baseball
being played. The Yankees unfortunately lost today. Very unfortunate.
That team did [__] garbage. I'm going to be honest
with you. It was not a good game. They were swinging at so many
fast balls down the middle and missing. But
again, >> did you see the British guy who pre-recorded
his stream to get away with murdering a woman? Um, I heard about
that. I'd heard that like basically it was pre-recorded and he
wasn't engaging with the chat at all. I'd heard about that. I
don't think I covered it ever. >> I want to make this very,
very clear.
I do wish my sincerest condolences to those two girls that were
the victims of an absolute senseless
tragedy.
And my >> a senseless tragedy. victims of a senseless tragedy.
And do you see how he's going back and forth between like implying
there's agency there and not on on the part of like what hurt
them?
That's that's weird, right? Like were the victims already implying
they were like something with intent hurt them, right? Of a senseless
tragedy.
Senseless
like senseless violence would make sense. Senseless tragedy.
I don't know if that makes sense. >> Hurt goes out to their
families. There can be there can be victims in uh in accidents
I suppose but then you no no no no then then you'd say if they're
victims that would be like due to some negligence someone else's
part right now I think accidents basically don't have
uh basically don't have victims like there has to be some other
force there I don't know tragedies can't be avoided
I don't know it it feels weird the back and forth he just did
there's
going on to one more stream there is one more stream here but
it's uh it's like a minute and then he pieces out again.
What is this?
>> Oh, is he just going to
>> Is Evan in here for co-op or >> fine? So, I hope
you guys are all ready. We're about to play some co-op.
>> Oh, Evan, he thinks Evan's there. 2v2
>> bro. Could you Oh, his live chat's back >> or
not. >> Oh, no. You're going to hate
>> 357
pine garwood. >> Okay, that's bad. That's pretty rough.
Okay, that's pretty rough. >> That's actually crazy.
>> That is actually kind of crazy.
>> Nah, nah, this stream's over, >> This stream's
over.
>> I'm pulling this car over right now.
>> This stream's over.
>> This stream's over. >> I'm not doing this [__]
>> This stream's over. That's That's
Um,
that's crazy. I That person shouldn't have done that though.
Yeah, there's Dude. Oh, thank you, Yzy Boss. Thank you. That's
a very helpful message now. It's a very very very helpful message
right there. Like a full minute after it happened. Okay, I I'm
not that worried about it. Um, from our end, I don't think anybody
is that invested from our end. But yeah, I'm going to read the
rest of the the article now. Give me a second. Is it this this
this this one? Okay. Coward of a man accused of New Jersey teens
in hit and run planned attack for months. Girls families say
the coward of a man 17-year-old accused of fatally striking two
New Jersey teen girls on their ebike was planning the attack
for months. The girls grieving family said Wednesday night. The
loved ones of Maria Neotus and Isabella Solless insisted the
deadly crash was far more depraved than a simple accident and
that the driver was targeting Maria specifically.
Now,
here's the rough thing. Okay, if he was if he was stalking the
one girl and it's a town over, I don't know what possible alibi
he could have, right? But he was just going for a drive. He just
drove over to this other town or something. I'm I'm guessing
it's only like 20 or 30 minutes away, but I don't know what the
alibi would be there. The loved ones of Maria Notus. Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. uh the two girls. Um the memorials out there,
tragic stuff. It is now vital that the truth be shared. This
was not an ebike accident and it was not a hit and run. The families
told Fox 5. There was a there was murder in Oh, sorry. This was
murder in the first degree. Hold on. Continue on.
Um I'm looking for I'm looking for where we can find this interview.
I want to find this Fox 5 interview. It is vital that the truth
be shared. This is not a ebike accident. The driver, a Garwood
resident who has not been identified by Union County prosecutors
because he's a minor, was slapped with two first-degree murder
charges on Wednesday. So, yesterday got first-degree murder charges.
So, the day after his stream, he got hit with first-degree murder
charges instead of just a hit and run with no like not vehicular
manslaughter,
actually getting hit with first-degree murder. So, I'm guessing
there's some proof that he was actually stalking these girls
or stalking one of them. Okay. He is related somehow to Christopher
Bat Batalaro, the police chief in the neighboring town of Westfield.
A coward of a man who has been plotting this attack against Maria
for months, carried out his horrific act, taking not only her
but also Isabella's uh not only her life but also Isabella's,
the families added or the memorial. He is not insane. He is competent
and uh meditated
Isabella's father told NJ.com his daughter didn't know the alleged
driver, but that Maria's mother told him her daughter was having
issue with the 17-year-old suspect issues. A friend of both girls
added that Maria and her ex-boyfriend were having serious problems,
and the ex even sent a threatening text to a boy that Maria dated
after they broke up. New Jersey.com reported one of the texts
reviewed by the outlet showed one of the teens telling the ex-boyfriend
that the school already told you to stop harassing her. Ooh,
hold on. Do we got texts here then? Hold on. Statement released
to Fox 5. I'm looking for where the actual texts are. One of
the texts reviewed Oh, text reviewed by the outlet showed the
one of the teens telling the ex-boyfriend, "The school already
told you to stop harassing her." Damn. So, these two were dating
and he was stalking his ex. It looks like the girls were mowed
down around 5:30 p.m. Monday as they rode an ebike in a leafy
suburb. The driver in a black 2021 Jeep with tinted windows fled,
but was arrested a short time later. The crash happened just
outside Maria's grandmother's home, and when a family member
saw the crash, they raced to help, unaware that Maria was involved.
The victims died at the hospital. Her best friend was Maria Isabelle's
father said they were hung together at the hip. A spokesperson
for the Union County Police uh prosecutor's office said Thursday
the criminal charges are currently a juvenile matter, so information
about the case is limited. The suspect, who is in custody, appeared
in court Thursday, but because he's a juvenile, it was not a
public hearing. He two beautiful girls. The grandmother told
nj.com he should pay. Jeez. Okay.
I kind of wanted to see is what's the language here? Text next.
X. What's next? Oh, Fox 5NY 7:45 p.m. That should have happened
today. Fox 5NY YouTube. Hold on. Let's see if we if we've got
this video here. Live live. L >> school together. And uh
police say they were murdered together when >> this is
the uh this is the actual video from 52 minutes ago. >> Run
over uh by a 17-year-old who has now, as I said, been charged
with two counts of firstdegree murder. And neighbors, as I mentioned,
had been telling us that uh the suspect would often park his
car outside one of the girls' homes and he had been reported
by the family to police and to the school. And this has been
happening for stalking allegedly for the last 3 months or so
um before this terrible tragedy happened according to police
and uh the family's attorneys. We're going to take you back now
live to the podium there as we await the parents uh to come and
make a statement tonight on this dark and tragic night for their
families. A wake is underway. Funeral services are also going
to be held on Saturday. We have Fox 5's Richard Gio who is at
the scene reporting. I wonder if they'll mention the live stream
or if they have to stay away from even pointing towards the identity
of the minor >> for us and has let us know that we are
expecting family. >> Is it because he's a minor that nothing
happened to stop him? He's under 18 too, right? Wait, what? Hold
on. What are you asking about posting online? Hold on. I need
to pull up the You're probably replying to somebody like I think
I think it's because he's under 18. They're not naming him. They
can charge him as an adult though, right? Maybe. But beyond don't
go live, you could say something bad. He said so much that was
so bad legally.
I feel like he said some things that show he didn't really like
care and he was saying it was an accident or he was saying it
was like a a tragedy. Like I think I think a judge looks at that
pretty pretty poorly. Not so much so that it like changes any
evidence. It's not evidence, but it when it comes to sentencing,
I think it could affect things for sure. They said the cops had
talked to him multiple times, but nothing had happened beyond
that. Oh, you're talking about I see. You're talking about in
terms of intervening beforehand. I'm guessing that like the
I'm guessing that this stuff is like probably almost not normal,
but like it's it happens and usually it doesn't lead to anything.
It's like edgy. It's like teenagers being emotional, hormonal,
and it doesn't lead to anything. And then sometimes this happens.
I'm guessing that's probably what it is, right? Usually usually
like people when they're being over when they're being hyperbolic
when they're younger, it's like not going to lead to
>> members to come to the podium at any minute. Um we'll
be following this story for you and let you know as it develops.
As soon as the parents are able to make it to the podium, we
will update you. That's on that story. Now, I told you it happened
in Cranford, New Jersey, but you're actually looking at a live
picture of Union, New Jersey because that's where the services
>> in their retribution efforts on the >> if the
Democrats had voted to keep the government open. >> Oh,
there's all the shutdown stuff here. I'm going to flick over
to this shutdown stuff. I'm going to use a bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back. >> And while the Senate's next vote
is not scheduled until Friday, President Trump is meeting with
his budget director, Russ Vote, who is already gearing up for
federal layoffs. >> It's likely going to be in the thousands.
And that's something that uh the Office of Management and Budget
and the entire team at the White House here again is unfortunately
having to work on today. These meetings would not be happening
if the Democrats had voted to keep the government open. >> Donald
Trump and Republicans have made clear they wanted to shut down
the government. They want to inflict pain on the American people.
They continue to engage in their retribution efforts. >> On
Capitol Hill, Democrats are fighting for CO era insurance subsidies
to be included in the spending bill. But Republicans claim their
proposal rolls back measures that prevents funds from going to
illegal migrants. >> There are things we can negotiate
differences we have. Uh and we're not going to give taxpayer
benefits to illegals, but don't hold the American people hostage
with a government >> This is about healthcare. He is choosing
to shut down the government rather than work with Democrats to
fix the healthc care crisis Republicans created. If Republicans
can't convince enough Democrats to change their votes on Friday,
Senate Majority Leader John Thun doesn't plan to keep lawmakers
here through the weekend. Instead, they'll likely try again on
Monday. >> Why? Why is the audio like this? Why is it doing
left channel, right channel like this? This is torture. >> Becca
Caster, Fox News. >> Jesus, this isn't paused. They just
froze on her face. >> And you're watching newsroom live.
That was Rebecca Caster reporting to us live in the Fox 5 Newsroom.
We're going to take you now to Union, New Jersey, where the family
members of two teenage girls >> the press conference here
>> Monday night are speaking. Here they are >> have
a few words to share with all of you. Their names are Sautios
and Foley. >> Good evening everyone. First, I want to thank
you all for being here today for showing up for Maria and for
standing beside me and my family during the hardest days of our
lives.
Your love, your prayers, and your presence mean more than words
can say. My name is
I'm not standing here today just as a mother, but as Maria's
mother, and that is the greatest title I will ever hold. Maria
was 17 years old, a high school senior, full of dreams, full
of life, and full of love. >> Hold on. What? Why did you
say this is relevant Kirk tent? Is this going to be a comment
on Charlie Kirk from him? Hold >> Hey, whenever Maria sees
the pizza guy come, better think of Charlie Kirk for making fun
of his death.
Stupid ass clown. Just remember that, >> dude. What, bro?
Is that Evan? >> Think of Charlie Kirk for making fun of
his death. >> Oh my
Jesus Christ.
Okay. So, like this guy is totally
This guy is completely
That's crazy.
Just to be clear that I don't think he's doing this because of
Charlie Kirk. Really? I think he had violent intentions before
this. I'm almost positive that he had violent intentions before
this. >> Nope. Outside.
>> One, two.
>> I'm going to go watch Charlie Kirk. One
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah. Apparently, she made fun of Kirk's
death on Tik Tok repost. So he sent her pizza as a prank with
a burner phone. Oh, >> lay down. I got to get drop tonight.
>> What did Evan say? >> I'm going to go watch Charlie
Kirk once I lay down. >> Oh, Evan is cringe. Never mind.
We're not fans of Evan Evan anymore. Okay, >> Evan's going
to go watch Charlie Kirk when he goes to lay down. That is gross.
>> I got to get pizza tonight. >> Hey, whenever Maria
sees the pizza guy come, better think of Charlie Kirk for making
fun of his death.
Stupid ass clown. Just remember that.
>> Now the restaurant's calling the number. Not answering
it.
>> That's work to walk. Yeah, I'm not answering that phone.
>> What were you saying? Did she What about Charlie Kirk?
>> No, she made fun of Charlie Kirk's death on TikTok on
a repost. >> Maybe her mother should uh monitor her social
media activities. So that's going to be a double play. >> [__]
I'm trying to Hold on. Yeah, some of this stuff's got transcripts.
I'm trying to go through and see,
bro. I I'm trying I'm multitasking here. I'm trying to go through
and see if I can find like a transcript search to go and see
anytime he's mentioned Maria. I think we should go search through
a bunch of his videos and look for Maria right now. >> What
were you saying? Does he What about Charlie Kirk? >> No,
she made fun of Charlie Kirk's death on TikTok on a repost.
>> Maybe her mother should uh monitor her social media
activities. That's going to be a double play,
>> I'm just going to You know what? I'll put in my phone.
I'll do that.
>> That's like That's crazy. He's just He seamlessly goes
back into his uh his baseball commentary. Well, so that's going to
be a double play right there.
>> Good luck trying to call my phone. >> 87 double
play. I don't know what the numbers are in baseball. I totally
>> The 248 double play some [__] >> Burner
phone. My burner phone.
>> Not my normal phone. my burner phone. Good luck. Not
coming to my watch either cuz I put that on do not disturb.
>> Okay, hold on. Hold on. Let's uh let's see if we find
other Maria references in the uh the time stamps here. >> I
think Maria's hungry. I think it's I think we're going to send
her a pizza. Cheer up. So,
you all know I have a vengeance against this girl for accusing
me of sending
Dude, hold on. I need to reset my headphones. And I'm like way
more I'm So I didn't realize how I didn't realize what we're
dealing with here. Okay, give me a sec. Okay, my Bluetooth headphones
are disconnecting and
this is not working. Can you guys hear me on the stream? Good.
You can hear me. Hold on. There we go. Reconnecting my headphones
now. Good. He's clicked back >> I think it's I think we're
going to send her a pizza. Sure. So, you all know I have a vengeance
against for accusing me of sending warning. So, you know, I have
a vengeance against this girl. What is he saying there? What
does that mean? A
I'm trying to see. Maybe I'm getting the word wrong here. >> I
have a vengeance against the
So, you all know I have a vengeance against the scaler.
>> A vengeance a tren
vendetta? No, I don't think it's vendetta. But he's saying, okay,
accusing me of doing what? Accusing me of sending >> Accusing
me of sending porn and [__] I'm gonna call a pizza
to her house. And here's how I'm going to do it. So, I told you
all that I bought the brand new iPhone 17 Pro Max the other day
and I'm going to be using this as my main phone now.
Better camera and [__] to do vlogs on.
But in the process,
>> I still have my iPhone 16 Pro Max.
And here's what I'm going to be doing. I'm going to be converting
this as a
>> So, what I'm going to do
>> is I'm going to
call Domino's
>> and I'm going to have a pizza sent to her house
>> and I'm going to tell the guy
the driver will be paid cash at the
>> Yes. Cash at the door. Bro, just as just as like prank
content, this is dog, too. I'm going to tell the driver, get
this cash at the door. I'm not even going to pay for the pizza.
Has anybody done this before? I'm not even going to pay for the
pizza, dude. You guys thought about this? Have you guys Have
you guys seen this?
>> or my dad wants to call you Fula. Don't fool me. Stupid.
You should not have accused me of
>> and you should not have dragged me into creating a police
report. So, >> oh
well that's something he might not have mentioned before. Apparently,
police report filed
um in the opposite
>> I got to do better. >> You made a bad decision
making a bad name of my of myself. You made a bad
>> Having this girl returned to that school without me
being there.
>> I think we're I think you're hungry. We're gonna send
you a pizzaressed
>> and get in the cell.
>> Use my burner. >> So Foola or my dad wants to
call you Foola. And what was the Yeah, we missed the mother's
name when she came out for the press conference. Hold on. Someone
introduces them. Let's listen again. >> Fooly. Fooly. So
yes, he is talking to her mother there.
Fooly foola.
Let's listen again.
>> or my dad wants to call you fula. Don't fool me. Stupid.
>> You should not have accused me of
>> and you should not have dragged me into creating a police
report.
>> you made a bad decision. Making a bad name of my of
myself. You made a bad
>> Having this girl returned to that school without me
being there.
>> I think we're I think you're hungry. We're going to
send you a pizza
and get in the setup.
>> Use my burner.
>> Does he Did he get like a new SIM card? And is it like
an actual is it some kind of SIM card that can't be tracked because
otherwise he's just using his old phone?
I don't
>> I'm pull
>> I'm going to use a VPN so I don't get trapped or like
>> Hold on. He's He's VPNing up, guys. He's going to be
fine. He's VPNing up. He's protected now.
>> You sure?
I don't know if I want to order five. That would raise some suspicion.
>> I'll order two. How about that? >> I'll order
two pizzas.
>> So, I have a VPN on and I'm going to call Domino's.
>> He's got a VP on VPN on. He's going to call Domino's.
So, he must be doing this through like I is he using like uh
what is it? It's not Google phone. It's like Google. I can't
remember what the Google like telephone app is called, but like
it what VIP service can you use anonymously? Google voice. Like
he'd have to have it set up anonymously or he's using
or he's using his actual like phone like his actual phone plan
in some way to call and he turned a VPN on. He thinks it helps.
I would love to I would love more of a breakdown here. Also,
I'm going to end on Twitch, guys, and head over to Kick. So,
guys, if you're watching on Twitch, head over to Kick right now.
Going to finish out the stream there. Thank you very much for
showing up, supporting on kick on Twitch. All right, real quick
before I go, uh, Himster, thank you for the primer. Thank you
for the primer.
move it over. We'll see you guys in just a minute. Okay, bye-bye.
Okay, kick only. Kick only. Kick only. Let's continue. I want
to order five. That would raise some suspicion.
>> Order like two people.
>> I'll order two. How about that? >> I'll order
two pizzas.
So, I have a VPN on and I'm going to call
>> I'm going to bring the camera closer
>> so you all can see what I'm about to do.
>> I'm going to put this on speaker. Okay,
>> bro. Why? I got to imagine that while not like a criminal
thing, falsely like ordering pizzas or anything to somebody's
house, that's got to be like a problem, right? There's got to
be some bylaw that you could get like fined for that or something,
right? There's got to be something. Why the [__]
would you stream it? >> Got to do better.
>> And here's the thing. All right. I did a lot in my free
time. So, you all know I bought my phone.
>> I bought
my AirPods Max.
And I bought this Apple Watch Ultra 3. >> Uhhuh. He's just
He's just bragging about being rich now.
>> So a lot on Apple tech. I actually been wearing it the
whole stream. So I spent
on that in total. Yeah, that was not cheap. But let's be honest,
>> it's better than spending 50 bucks on snacks, Maria.
Don't you think? So, you know what? We're going to get you a
>> We're calling Domino's. >> What's their number?
272,000. Call them right now. That's what I'm doing. Right now.
That's what I'm doing. Give me a second right now. >> You
mark my words, JTock. The mother did it. I don't think so. I
I think it's probably the guy who says he wants vengeance or
he has a vengeance against this girl and is obsessing about her
and ordering pizzas to her house a week before the the actual
murders took place. And the guy who got arrested and pulled out
of the vehicle, it's not even a mystery. They caught the vehicle
that ran those girls over. They caught the vehicle. They arrested
this guy driving the vehicle. How the [__] did the
mom sigh up this guy? Sigh up this guy into being in the vehicle.
How'd that happen? It's not even a question that he did it. It's
a question of whether or not it was an accident, but that's not
even a question either. This guy's guilty. This guy's the most
guilty mother I've ever >> Let me make sure. Yep. Okay.
>> We'll be right with you. >> This Domino's is now
hiring for all positions. Please apply online at
>> We'll be right with you to take your
>> Have you tried our new marble cookie brownie? It's an
irresistibly warm and
>> Order one of them,
>> Hi, can I place an order for delivery,
>> What's that address?
>> He's got a VPN on while admitting to it on stream. You
got You just love to see it. Okay, they'll never catch me. I've
got a VPN on and I stream with a with a YouTube channel tied
to my name directly, guys. They'll never They'll never figure
it out.
>> Can I get >> That's That is uh a little bit surprising
that he Listen, maybe that's why he was so mad. He was so mad
about himself getting doxed on his stream because he was like,
"Dude, I was I was planning to kill this person and even I to
dox them." There's There's some things that just go too far.
Two large pepperoni pieces.
>> That's it.
>> No drinks. No drinks.
>> It'll be cash at the door.
>> Okay. Thank you very much.
>> And I have the VPN on so I can't get tracked. Oh,
>> you should go to the house and see. >> Dude, the
All I know for sure is Okay. Where's that person? Where's this
person? Okay, this person was right. All right. Whatever they're
doing in American schools, you guys have been failed completely.
You guys have been failed by the American schooling system.
This guy's
This guy's lost. This guy is the average American zoomer. Okay,
>> pull up.
>> Should I do Here's the thing, though. I did that the
last time, but the mother saw me pull up in the car.
>> Whoa. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
>> No, I did that.
Bro, this guy just keeps This guy is like straight up putting
on the record that he was stalking this girl. I >> mean,
you should go to the house and see the people who pull up.
>> Should I do Here's the thing, though. I did that the
last time, but the mother saw me pull up in the car and I got
tracked. And you should pull up, Evan. Evan says, "You should
pull up
and watch the pizza get delivered."
He responds, in case you can't hear it. He responds, "Yeah, I
did that last time, but the mom caught me and tracked me." >> The
police, you know, did what they did.
>> And the police did what they did.
Wait, did the the have the police visited him about this before?
Okay, now it's starting to look bad. Right now, I'm starting
to wonder. So, we know from reading some of the articles that
he's got either a dad or an uncle who's the chief of police in
the town he's in, right? It's I'm getting concerned that maybe
this guy was showing real signs that he was going to hurt somebody
and the cops kept sweeping under the rug because of some connection.
Like that's that's what I'm more concerned about. Well, sorry.
That's Yeah, he's guilty. So that's what I'd be most concerned
about right now is is basically like was this guy a ticking time
bomb that they ignored because he has family connections at the
top of the police departments in these places. >> Should
I do I don't think I should do >> All right. All right.
>> All right. All right. All right. >> So, I'm going
to put my phone on silent.
>> All right.
>> Yeah. I don't want this. I don't want to hear this.
And I don't want to hear when the police come to my door.
>> Have fun with your pizza. >> I'm going with your
pizza, fool. >> How did the How did the transcript show
foola there? Foola. Foola. Okay. Oh, hold on.
Oh, we see f Oh, hold on.
Where is this? This is 2 hours 16. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. Look at this. So, we we'll save this time stamp here
real quick. This is where we were. This is an hour before. Okay.
He was still seething about the same thing. >> I got to
pull it up. So, it's going to take me a few seconds.
>> This is >> Chad is covering the transcript. Don't
worry about it. >> You're going to sound very crazy.
>> What are you putting on there?
Which one are you gonna pick? >> It's going to sound very
crazy.
>> This is gonna sound very crazy.
>> What are you putting on there? >> Which one are
you going to pick?
>> Which prank call?
>> Yeah. Like which prank model? >> I have the one
in mind. So here's what I
Believe it or not, I have Foola's
background check and her phone numbers and like that and I have
it all right. >> So, is he again right here confessing
to getting police specific details from one of his family members
and using them to harass the woman the the mother of the girl
he's stalking. This is this guy is not just like fed posting
on himself anymore. He is like actually fed posting on his entire
>> Right here
I have a list of phone numbers that I can call and I'm gonna
be doing that. And uh y'all are probably going to ask how I did
that. Well, let's just say I got a lot a lot a lot of
>> You're probably thinking I got that off the internet.
But let me tell you, I have a lot of connections to law enforcement.
Okay, I've got a lot of connections. You might think that I have
some plausible deniability that protects my family from any accusations
here, but just in case you thought that, I'm going to clear that
up for you and I'm going to make sure you know that it was my
dad or my uncle or whoever.
So, here's what we're going to do.
>> We're going to do this.
>> And I want to make sure
I'm going to type in numbers. I actually do I need my um Actually,
maybe not. I might not need my uh
well, I got to I got to look and see.
Okay,
so
I don't know if this will work.
I have a few numbers here on my phone. And what I'm going to
do, he prank calla. I'm guessing that what he's I thought what
he was going to do is eventually this turns into the the ordering
pizzas, but that's like later on too. that's like an hour later
when he starts ordering the pizzas >> is
I'm going to do a prank dial on her
>> and it'll be non-traceable so nothing's going to happen
and I'll explain that in a minute. So I have a one I have a one
in mind. Um I don't know if you have one in mind but I'm also
going to do the hit my car because that [__] is funny.
What I'm going to do is
I'm going to find a name because I tried to um
I tried to search up the name Foola. That name >> Don't
worry guys, he's got a VPN. He's got a VPN. It's totally untraceable.
They'll never figure out it was him. The only way they could
catch him is if they just looked at the YouTube channel he probably
talks about to all of his friends he can't stop yapping about
that's tied directly to a to a username that's tied to his real
life name. Right. That's the only way they can figure it out.
>> Name is not on there. So I have to try to find a different
name
use. Uh
I'm going to use freedom. It's close. It's not the right pronunciation.
It's kind of close enough,
>> I'm just speeding up a little bit until we figure out
what I know what color car she and then I'm going to customize
it to make it fun.
>> Now, here's the thing.
>> Fooly uses a 551,
>> but the problem is I don't think I think that's just
like a madeup number for when she lived in a different country.
So, I'm not going to try that one yet.
>> I'm going to try this one. I have to verify another
phone number real quick.
>> So, I got to do that. So, I'm going to verify by SMS.
>> Wait, whatever he's signing up with. Why wouldn't it
verify?
I don't know exactly. He must be signing up for like the like
a VIP service or something,
>> It's going to take a while for this to
in my face. You say, "Hey, hey, what's your problem? Why you
talking like that?" When I picture
a wild
>> Oh, sure. Vip
these things take a long time. Okay, here we go.
>> Sign in.
So to that
>> Okay. Why does it tell me to verify my
>> Hold on.
That's verified. Uh
>> no, I don't want to pay again. First of
Didn't I um >> Why does it tell me to try the app? I have
an account for this. Did I log in through Google? >> Hang
on. You know what? Hold on. I'm hoping I'm hoping that it's not
just a VPN, but maybe it is. >> I think I know. I have
an idea. I'm hoping he'll go far enough to say exactly what he's
trying to log into right now.
>> I think I put You know what? I probably
>> Yeah, I put it here.
>> I'm going to see. I think I have an
>> Let me bring the controller over here.
>> I have an idea of why it's not working.
>> What the get started
with Apple.
>> Allow access to contents.
>> Hold on. Is that why it doesn't work?
I think I know why it doesn't work.
>> I'm making sure of it before I
>> Oh, wait. >> Wait, I think I got it. Yeah, I got
it. I guess it just glitched out. Okay, so I can use this
to get the verification code from Prank Dial.
Oh, hold on. Frog verified by SMS.
>> He's signing up for something like this. That's like
literally just so you can do these. He's literally said the service
that he's logged in with via Google. Is this what he thinks a
VPN is or is is that it's actually pretty decent? Okay. But like
he has to understand that anything he's doing through this service
is going to come back to him, right? I he doesn't seem to at
all.
>> Okay. So, we're going to send the prank from that number.
>> So, I'm going to try one number.
>> I don't know if it'll work. There's nine numbers here.
So, I'm going to try this one first. Okay. Okay. So, that gets
us to we're we're back now to the actual prank call he's trying
to do to Domino's.
Still looking through some of this stuff. I'm getting ready to
go through some of the other videos, too. I want to see if there
are other other mentions of this all going on. So, he's he calls
Domino's. He says he's ordering two pizzas. He gets an order
to their house. There's a little bit there. If you just joined
late, okay, if you just joined late, he says stuff like his friend
suggests, "Hey, you should go watch the pizza get delivered at
her house." and he says, "Oh, no, no, no." Like, "I already did
that once. I pulled up there. The mom saw me. They tracked my
vehicle and the cops like got mad at me." So, he he like confesses
to having stalked her in this little blurb here. Okay. I do want
to keep going with this because I want to see if we get back
to um I want to see if we get back to >> All right, guys.
We're going to play another room game. >> Oh, never mind.
Him talking about this again. All right. I'm going to look through
for the names as well. Uh Maria. Maria there. Maria there. Okay.
Okay. Hey, whenever Maria >> Oh, right, right, right, right.
This is This is the clip that got us here. Okay.
>> Hey, whenever Maria sees the pizza guy come, better
think of Charlie Kirk for making fun of his death. Stupid ass
clown. Just remember that.
>> Restaurant calling the number. Not answering it.
>> That's a walk. Yeah, I'm not answering that phone. >> What
were you saying? That she What about Charlie Kart? No, she made
fun of Charlie Kirk's death on Tik Tok on a repost. Maybe her
mother should uh monitor her social media activities. So, that's
going to be a double play. >> Isn't it just >> I'm
just going to You know what? I'm putting my phone. I'll do my
mistake.
>> Good luck trying to call my phone. My burner phone.
My burner phone. >> What 22 card? >> The collection
one. The Takahashi.
>> Oh, what? What the world's going on? >> I was
going to say you better make that play. This isn't gym time.
Your gym time is running the ball and catching. Maria doesn't
like to do >> pass the ball. >> I Dude, he like goes
in and out of talking about her, too. So, I skip forward about
5 minutes. >> She likes to eat fat and be a pig.
>> Oh, Maria doesn't like to go to the gym. She likes to
eat fat and be a pig. Okay. >> And likes to wear makeup.
She doesn't like being insecure.
>> Multiple shows better than that one. >> I'm kind
of scared to open the burn. >> Yeah. Something tells me
I got like 50
>> while I'm doing not dirty. Something tells me I'm giving
up a bomb
>> or walking him because he can't locate for some reason.
>> So May hit a home run earlier. Haven't given up.
>> I'm sorry.
>> Don't bring up hard time, man. >> Know on you
all want to know.
Not that any of it meant. Well, that's two ball for sure. Y'all
want to know what my heart rate is?
It was >> We don't want to know what your heart rate is
>> in [__] 12
>> 27 minutes ago. Can you believe that? >> Why is
your heart What? >> I wonder what it is now. >> I
wonder, >> bro. That is some gamer genetics right there.
100 heart rate while you're sitting down playing baseball.
That's crazy. Okay. Okay.
I think so. What's happening here is I'm just going through getting
context cuz I see a bigger story here, right? I see the whole
thing unfolding.
I see him talking about this girl and talking about like his
parents telling him to stop talking about this girl.
Listen to this. It's about his dad >> and my personality.
>> Hey Vinnie, next year I'm going to fly you out. >> Hold
on. Hold on. >> I can't wait to imagine what Ripper
>> His He He He's probably on the verge of death with his
rage.
>> Ripper's account.
>> The guy the guy who likes to call me a That's why I'm
the way I am. cuz people don't. Maybe if I had a sibling, maybe
if I wasn't an only child, maybe I'd have actually somebody to
guide on to maybe if people actually understood me and my personal.
>> Bro, this is actually this is just Elliot Roger
with like even worse genetics, right? Like this is this is Elliot
Roger all over again where this guy is talking about how he's
misunderstood, how he's the real victim. It's this is like a
little harrowing. I I can't believe this isn't blowing up all
over the place.
>> Hey, Vinnie. Next year I'm going to fly you out to Atlanta.
>> Say less. >> I'm do it for a vacation. Honestly,
cuz when I'm 18, honestly, my my dad can't tell me what [__]
to do. >> That's That's not even there. How old >> I
could? >> Wait, how old is How old is this guy?
>> When you turn 18, I'm going fly you out. >> for
it? But I thought I was going to get past him. So >> I
picked a blaz. Maria's got version.
>> Also, open up the top LSF post. Got more links. All
right. >> Be fairly honest.
>> Maybe I got the LSF post here.
>> maybe my parents are part of the problem. Listen, my
mom has been hospitalized for sight.
>> For what?
>> My dad is not very good on >> I see. Right. So
maybe people need to understand
when you get two of those combinations, it doesn't really give
you that good of a son, does it? >> I don't know. >> I
don't know. Listen, one of them is blind, the other one's a drunk,
you don't get a good kid coming out of that, right? I don't know.
>> You want to focus up and not [__] up this
co-op game, bro? >> Makes you a good MLB The Show player.
Probably not.
>> Uh, makes you a great MLB The Show player. All right.
Not good for generally being generally being well adjusted. But
listen, in this in this one place, I am king. Okay, MLB the show.
Yo, Subbox Society, thank you for the nine months. Let's go.
>> You know what? Don't take notes. Don't take notes. Don't
listen. I don't want any of you to be a [__] with
me.
>> Have you ever been to Atlanta? >> I've just been
unlucky. Give me one second. Say that again. >> You ever
been to Atlanta?
>> All right. Well, next year if you'd like to come down
here, I'm sure I can find you a cheap flight or something. >> The
count's full. >> I haven't been to an MLB game in six years.
Seven years.
>> Jeez. Well, we can go to one. >> That's four.
>> Yeah. No, I would like to go to one. My >> Okay,
hold on. I'm looking for the next clip here. Next clip is
him talking two months ago. This is him talking about stalking,
doing crazy >> Instagram stories. I posted the story. If
you all have not seen my um Instagram stories, I posted the story
time on this police report and because the investigation is now
fully over because again this boy is not cooperating with the
investigation. So they actually closed it for good this time.
So I'm not getting charged with this. >> If you
have not seen on my stories, I posted the report and the
body cam. That's a base hit for MLAN. I posted the body cam of
it.
In order for you guys to watch it, you need to be a subscriber
to the Instagram. It is vincent.bal. You'll see a subscribe button.
You have to pay for it. I know. But
there's stuff that on that report I really don't want getting
too much to the public. >> Bro, what?
>> But trust me, it is worth watching. Throw a second is
not going to get him. >> I have to I'm listening to that
whole thing over again. One second,
dude. I I have this clicking going on in my headphones again.
I need to reset these. I'm I'm at the point where I'm ready to
invest in wired headphones. This is too much. This is just too
much with the And it's like taking forever to disconnect because
there's something going wrong with the Bluetooth driver or something.
I don't even know. Please.
All right. Here we go. >> Instagram stories. I posted the
story
the the fact that you know
>> if you all have not seen my um Instagram stories I posted
the story time on this police report and because the investigation
is now fully over because again this boy is not cooperating with
the investigation so they actually closed it for good this time
so I'm not getting charged with this >> if you
have not seen on my stories I posted the report and the
body cam that's a base hit MLAN. I posted the body cam of it.
>> Okay. So, the cops have stopped him and there is body
cam footage of this. I'm guessing you'll never be able to access
it. It's probably all protected or all sealed because he's a
minor, right? Like none of this stuff will actually be in the
public outside of him if somebody like archived this from his
Instagram story cuz I'm guessing because he's a minor, he's going
to get protected. There's not going to be any of this stuff made
public. >> In order for you guys to watch it, you need
to be a subscriber to the Instagram. It is Vincent. Battle. see
a subscribe button. You have to pay for it. I know, but
there's stuff that on that report I really don't want getting
too much to the public,
>> but trust me, it is worth watching. Throw a second is
not going to get him. Oh, and two, but if you want to see more,
subscribe to the Insta and you'll see the that went down there.
I I'll give you a hint. I think that's caught. >> No, it's
not. Oh my god. Yeah, that is a lot of glitching. I'm not going
to lie. And gonna score. Oh boy. I don't I don't need the picture
for the one.
>> I don't need the picture, right? >> Bro, can he
stop playing the show for two seconds so he can confess to all
of his wrongdoing? >> No. Why does my hair look like a
brat?
>> But yeah, subscribe to the Insta if you want exclusive
content of that
>> on one. >> And she's getting her whole team to
gang up on me. If I saw her in real life, she would be scared
to even see my face. Okay.
And I only say that because
>> somehow
someway,
you know, I guess the brother >> of her got the report
and said, "Pull up to the house." When I said I would, the brother
got all scared and backed out
like a scaredy-cat. He's >> When I threatened to show up
at their house, suddenly everybody started taking it seriously.
>> Dumb. Okay, he went back. He got all scared and backed
out and said, "I really don't want to fight." And then the girl
in the body cam said, "I don't expect you to realize how scared
I am because he threatened to hurt me." So he the brother said,
"Come to the house." >> Dude, this is this is going to
turn into this is going to be massive. This is going to turn
into a whole scandal, right? There's police body cam footage
of this girl who got run down crying about this dude terrifying
her. And there, this is on camera. Like, he doesn't understand
what he is telling all of us. And I'm looking at some of the
other quotes for some of the other clips, but we won't release
it.
Wait, what? Oh, yeah, dude. In any case, surprised you didn't
stream it himself at this point, right? So, I don't think they'll
release that stuff to the public. It'll it'll go to some court
and then I'm sure journalists will be able to see it and read
about it as well. >> It's not worth my time seeing two
scaredy shifts. I would easily win that fight. It's not worth
my time. What the How did he drop that ball? Okay, it's two nothing.
>> I thought he was going to catch that, but he didn't.
That >> was a weird animation. >> That was should
have been out of the inning. That's not on you. That's on the
damn fielder. I don't know what he was
>> 0 and one. I got throws inside. Got a good swing on
it, but right to him.
That is insane. I don't know why people are not thinking like
this. would have already been big by now, but I don't think it's
going to go anywhere. You're out of your mind, J. Good. You're
out of your mind. This is all insane like content gold.
No, this is all insane content gold right here. You have no idea
what you're talking about. Everybody's going to call this. It's
going to blow up massively
and and there's going to be like investigations into the cops.
I I feel like I'd bet on this. >> Jesus Christ. Okay, so
steps up. Let's see if I can get lucky with my >> Okay,
that I can't do much with. I'm not going to lie. So, I can only
just sit and watch at that. >> That's a good pitch inside.
>> I figured now I'm decided to lock in since it's co-op.
>> I don't know if he's going to say more on this stream.
I
>> So, this is the same This is the same video, right?
We just heard this right >> Instagram stories. I posted
>> the story time >> on this police report and because
the investigation is now fully over because >> Okay, hold
on. Is this a different one? This might be different for >> I
took a hiatus from streaming. >> So this is 4 months ago.
>> It's time for a different change. So that's why we're
going into this new game live on YT or should I say Tik Tok or
live streaming in general. Number one, MLB's kind of, you know,
the content hasn't been like very much
achieving
in, you know, what I would like to see. So I've been kind of
taking a break from that. and so has uh Evan
and I we believe you know it's time for a different we believe
that it's time for a different change. So that's why we're going
into this new game that I'll mention in a second. But I want
to also >> is he really throwing he's throwing Evan under
the bus? How did Evan stuck by him? Okay. When this guy was accused
of murder in the first degree, Evan stuck by him and now he's
throwing his co-op content with Evan under the bus. >> No
such thing as loyalty these days. something else that you know
has uh been on my mind. I took a hiatus from streaming
and this has to do with my personal life and this involves school.
I got a bunch of allegations being handed to me
of
crazy stuff I will deny
for 50 years to the end of my life.
ridiculous allegations that
this girl is making against me and over
because I got into her relationship business and now the school
and now I'm going to tell you all this cops got involved.
>> Dude, this is four months ago. Okay, he got into her
relationship business.
What does that mean? I don't know. >> Then the school got
involved in this and somehow they're believing this crap. So
they suspended me basically indefinitely until they figured which
makes again makes no sense
because they should have waited until they were if if they're
really believing this is true criminal charges filed which there
haven't been cuz this is all bogus. So that's happened.
I'm waiting to see you know when I get this appointment for my
they want to test me for a savory assessment and which I don't
even understand it. I have the digital copy. They sent me a digital
copy. >> It's me, Rose. I lick you. You are cut. >> They
gave me this digital cop. I I showed you all that hard copy on
which I think was very unprofessional. The >> is cut.
>> I think that was very unprofessional how he wrote it.
Looked like [__] A four-year-old can write better
than
>> Did he kill her? Yes. So, uh, we read the article. He
was arrested at like in the vehicle that ran them down. So,
uh, so the girls were mowed down at 5:30 p.m. Monday as they
rode an ebike in a leafy suburb. The driver in a black 2021 Jeep
with tinted windows fled but was arrested a short time later.
So, he literally he just got caught like 100% he got caught.
Did you see that last chat? Nope. What was your last chat? Anyway,
we we're continuing. Hold on. Where is it? Where'd I put it?
This one. >> Dr. Ken, it went over this stuff of, you know,
how I'm being accused of, you know, sending questionable chats
and stuff like that. previous chat from Rose. I am Rose. Who
is you? Vinnie, you is
wait. Yeah, this is like an Indian man trying to pick this guy
up or something. I have no idea. >> Was very unprofessional
the way that guy wrote that. >> Vinnie, you is
>> I think that was very unprofessional to
Vinnie, bark for me. I'm waiting to see, you know, when I get
this appointment for my They want to test me for a savory assessment
and which I don't even
>> what
I'm waiting to see, you know, when I get this appointment for
my they want to test me for
a savory assessment and which I >> a savory assessment.
What is a savory
>> Don't even understand it. I have the digital copy. They
sent me a digital >> It's me, Rose. I lick you. You are
cut. >> They gave me this digital cop. I I showed you all
that hard copy on which I think was very unprofessional. The
way that guy wrote that >> Vinnie, you cut.
>> I think that was very unprofessional how he wrote it.
Looked like a four-year-old can write better than that doctor
can. It went over this stuff of, you know, how I'm being accused
of, you know, sending questionable chats and stuff like that.
And now
what? >> Choice of words. Yeah, they're twisting my words
basically. They're the ones making these
>> accusations and stuff like that. So, police got involved
>> Oh, me and the app. God damn it. I just clicked forward.
God damn it. >> Showed you all that hard copy on which
I think was very unprofessional. >> All right. Now, I got
two announcements. >> They're the ones making these >> right
here. Right here and stuff like that. So, police got involved.
>> Stuff like that.
I'm waiting to see what the investigation is on that, but until
then, I can't go back to school, which basically mean because
it's indefinite, I can stay up as late as I want while I'm streaming,
which is kind of sad. >> At least he's seeing a silver
lining. I'm suspended from school, but uh you know, at least
I can stream whatever I >> Same time, you know, it hasn't
it it doesn't really affect, you know, I can stream as long as
I want now. I can make content as much as I want. >> All right,
now I got two announcements. >> But hold on, I'll be finished
in a second. So, what was I going to say, >> dude? Evan's
like, "Yeah, I'm we're going to be streaming late night now."
>> I forgot what I was going to say. That is why I haven't
been streaming. It's taken a deep effect on my mental health.
But because of the support of my mom and dad who are both defending
these bogus allegations and [__] which I think is
sick, twisted out, and outlandish, they're defending me. They
They wanted to search my phone. The school wanted to search my
phone and [__] but my dad told him that my dad refused.
get a warrant and then we can talk from there.
I
like that's that reflects so poorly on his father as a parent
that his father like was like, "No, no, no. You can't search
you can't search my son's phone." And then didn't take any steps
to step in himself and make sure that there wasn't something
like crazy going on. So, I got to wait and see, you know, when
I can get this appointment. And until then,
again, this is taking effect, but with the support of my parents,
I feel comfortable enough, I feel healed enough where I can go
back to streaming.
And I'm also taking an MLB break because
I feel like with the stress that I'm having and you know, if
we lose games and like that, perfect. The rage moments are not
going to help. And to be fairly honest again, we were going to
take a break anyway because Evan also said >> uh dad W
for protecting his son's rights to be honest. So I would think
that most of the time Oompi killer but this guy then went and
murdered the girl the school suspected him of harassing and being
obsessed with ran her and an innocent another innocent girl down.
So unfortunately here we know not w dad that l dad. Okay. L dad
raised a murderer didn't care. Didn't engage in his son's life.
Okay. Lad
>> says that the content has been very overwhelming
and we were supposed to have criminal on for the stream, but
he says that his PS5 is broken and it's getting fixed right now.
Some I looked and it said somebody was playing on his account.
He claimed that, you know,
>> one of the guys fixing his console was playing on it
to test it, but I don't know. So, we're going to be playing this.
It's it's
undetermined when we're going to go back to playing MLB. We'll
announce that at a later time, but me and Evan and KMAN have
agreed to go to play GTA
for an extended period of time. I bought a modded account as
you guys will see in a little bit. It cost me a lot of money,
$200. What we're going to do tonight is we're going to do a heist
and I have to we have to do the steps of setting it up cuz I
haven't bought a um arcade yet. But with the money I have, that
shouldn't be a problem. We're to get an arcade. Go through the
setups, >> dude. Okay. All right. Right. Yeah. He's buying
accounts. I'm sitting here and I'm like, "Okay, you're you're
like in high school. You're suspended. You want to be an influencer
or some Why are you streaming for an hour? What is this? What
is this lazy? You're streaming for an hour, brother. You got
all the time in the world. You're streaming for an hour. For
real. For real.
This guy's like, "Oh, I can stream way more." When When are you
going to stream more? Okay, this is going back to another stream
two months later. I don't know if we put this clip on yet or
not yet. >> Still not basically welcome back until I do
it.
>> all of the all the time stamps from the subreddit are
leaving out like so much >> decision can't be which may
which >> dude he's still >> so we're going to do
that. We're going to head right on to it. And I actually want
to tell you guys something about this whole thing. Obviously,
you know, >> how many concurrent viewers did he have? He
seems to get between like three and five in a lot of these earlier
streams >> with this whole situation that I'm going through.
I'm not facing charges and because again all of this stuff that
has been proven already has been a lie.
I talked to my school about what has happened and believe it
or not they're still making me go for a savory >> A sa
I so like sane sane savory. Oh, savory risk assessment. A structured
assessment of violence risk in youth. Oh, okay. Somebody pointed
this out. This is a risk assessment. Can I get a
can I get an outline of this? APA psychet. The
the structured assessment of violence risk in youth. Savory
uh is a structured professional judgment tool for assessing violence
risk in adolescence between the ages of 12 and 18. for the purposes
of using the instrument. Violence is defined as an act of So
they're trying to do this assessment of him to see if he's a
risk for violence. His parents are denying, he's denying. He's
been out of school for months. It seems like two months between
four months ago was the stream where he said he wasn't going
to be allowed back until he took the test. And then at 2 months,
he's saying they're still not allowing me back until I take the
test. This is >> I have >> it's baffling. It's baffling.
>> Absolutely no clue why it >> uh hold on. Okay,
hold on. Hold on. Hold on. All of this stuff that has been proven
already has been a lie.
I talked to my school about what has happened and believe it
or not, they're still making me go for a savory assessment. I
have absolutely no clue why. >> Now, the story of a wealthy
family. >> Oh my god. I didn't even get the I didn't even
get the right song. I didn't even get the right song. Oh, I was
trying to do a meme. I'm
Listen, I'm off my game, okay? I'm I'm up. I It's fine. We're
continuing.
>> I've shown no deviency and no violence
>> and we've tried to appeal the decision and apparently
that decision can't be which may which doesn't >> I was
I was going to roll over to this with the the music. Okay. Just
going to It's fine. I need to start closing some of these so
I can actually stay on the the actual VOD I'm looking at here.
>> It makes sense because Oh, we can app >> I'm just
backing it up just a little bit. see no violence
and >> it's the curb theme I was looking for. >> and
we've tried to appeal the decision and apparently that decision
can't be which m which doesn't make sense because oh we can appeal
the school expulsion but we can't appeal a savory assessment
that I don't find to be making any sense. Oh that oh we hold
the card. No you don't. You can authorize a decision making on
whether I do this [__] or not. So they will not although
my expulsion has been rescended, I'm still not basically welcome
back until I do it. And my dad is arguing with the school about
it. He's going to have a meeting with the superintendent about
it to voice his frustrations.
>> So no, no, no. My son doesn't have to take that test
to to do a risk assessment of his proclivity for violence, like
an assessment of the risk of physical violence he might present.
And I'm going to keep running this up the chain until you just
let him back in the school. You get into a fight with Maria in
school. So, he got he got expelled and I'm guessing it's for
stalking this girl. It seems like it's for stalking this girl.
>> I don't know what'll happen next, but for right now,
it's not looking good. >> I don't know when we're ordering.
>> And there may come a point
where I might have to go to a different school. So, I'm going
to invite you, Evan. I don't know if you can hear me,
but I'm going >> If they If they refuse to let me in, I
just might have to I I feel like that's normally what people
do after they get expelled is they enroll in a different school.
No.
>> What's What's happening? Okay, hold on a second. Just
I'm trying to order some food here. Uh I'll just Okay, I'm back.
>> Invite you to this lobby. >> There might not be
any more from this >> but it's sad. But it's just >> it's
honestly sad that I'm being found innocent and I'm basically
be basically being black bowled like Trevor Bower can't enter
a school. It's ridiculous.
And you know what? Because
while we didn't stream, there was a new update. >> Trevor
Bower,
professional baseball player who's a pitcher for the Yokohama
Dina Bay Stars of the Japanese Professional League. Now, how
did he get what's what's the assault allegations? In June 2021,
Bowerer was placed on administrative leave, investigated by the
Pasadena police. I'm I'm like this guy who's accused of of violence
against women. I'm like that guy. I'm They're treating me like
that guy,
dude. There's no There's no shot. There's no shot. B is placed
on administrative leave and investigated by the Pasadena Police
Department for the alleged assault of a San Diego woman named
Lindsay Hill earlier that year. In response to the allegations,
the Dodgers removed Bower's merchandise from their team store.
He remained under investigation by MLB police through MLB and
police through the 2021 season, but the Los Angeles County District
Attorney's Office elected not to file criminal charges, citing
a lack of evidence. Bowerer sued Hill for defamation, and she
filed a counter claim alleging sexual battery. Both suits were
settled in 2023 with neither party admitting any wrongdoing and
no money changing hands. Bower released a video that October
saying he was happy to be moving on with his life. He filed a
new lawsuit against Hill citing a breach of settlement in October
2024. On June 2nd, 2025, Bower was awarded just over $300,000
from Hill in a default judgment. While Bower was under investigation
in 2021, the Washington Post uncovered court records showing
that a separate woman from Ohio had sought a temporary order
of protection in June 2020. A third woman accused Bower in 2022
and 2023. He denied all of these allegations. Oh,
he a lot of things. So, I'm guessing he basically seems he's
probably not quite good enough, right? Oh, he's also political.
I see. Sounds like a great guy. I don't know anything about baseball.
We're doing Trevor Bower. So, he just compared himself to this
guy. He said, "I'm getting blacklisted like that guy got blacklisted."
Sorry, we're on this VOD, right? >> Trevor Bower can't
enter innocent and I'm basically be basically being blackballed
like Trevor Bower can't enter a school. It's ridiculous.
And you know what? Because
while we didn't stream, there was a new update that came out.
It was the money fronts update.
So, you basically have, let's see, the rapid VG GTX. You know
what? Yeah, we'll buy that. Again, since this is a modded >> uh
Bower was a Sai Young winner and he was basically still in his
prime when he was blacklisted. Oh, that's crazy. Then, I thought
he just wasn't good enough to make it in the MLB. B was crying
about how they were cheating. The MLB wasn't doing anything with
uh
MLB had some guys going around using illegal substances to increase
grip strength on baseballs. Allowing pitchers to spin put more
spin on the ball. Power. Oh, so he's got a lot of things. >> Literally
get whatever the you want. Everything is full. Jeez. Oh my god.
Everything's full. Um these houses are full of garages or full
of uh full of cars. All right. We're going to replace uh I have
a lot of banshees.
Jesus Christ. Oh, guess I got it to somewhere. All right, so
we got that. Let's see. The Uber M. Whatever the this is. Where
did I put it? The arena. Oh, the casino penthouse. That's right,
cuz I didn't have it. Okay, so this is the >> Okay, skip
forward a little bit till the next time he talks about it. >> With
July 4 already passing, I hope you guys had a hope you all are
having a good
Saturday night. With July 4 already passing, I hope you guys
had a good Fourth of July weekend. Hope you all are
having a good summer so far. I wish I could say the same, but
you know, with school [__] with legal, it's not ideal
what I'm dealing with now.
So,
but I hope you guys are doing good. That's all that matters.
All right, we're going to return this vehicle to storage. What
we're going to do is call in. Okay, I can't I'm I searched a
couple keywords. I'm looking for anything else. I don't see anything
else in this VOD. That looks like it. So, right now, I'm just
I've been going back and forth from this LSF thread to keep throwing
stuff up on stream from uh from all this. Oh, not this one. Hold
on. It's different LSF thread. This guy
People have been going through his VODs, combing through trying
to find anything. I' I found a couple of his VODs don't have
transcripts, so that kind of sucks, right? I can't JTO be like,
"This dude play games while chatting with us." Nah. Nah. Uh,
assulting the victim's mother's name. We watched this one on
stream.
>> This one,
>> or my dad wants to call you Fula. Don't fool me. Stupid
name.
>> You should not have accused me of sending porn.
>> And you should not have dragged me into creating a police
report.
>> So,
fool.
>> You made a bad decision making a bad name of my of myself.
You made a bad
>> Hold on. This uh this post was I live in the town over.
Kid was constantly being covered for covered up for. Covered
up for. Okay,
let's see here. This is what somebody said in a post, so not
sure if it's true. I live in this area and have found out that
the kid hit uh kids hit by the car were 17 to 18 year olds and
it was done on purpose by a boy the same age. Apparently, they
were run over multiple times and it was very gruesome. Oh, gross.
Oh, I didn't know this part. This detail has not been shared.
I heard the asalent was a psych was a psycho as a kid, assaulted
a principal, sexually assaulted a female student, and was expelled.
The victim had a restraining order against the asalent from previous
time when the boy had harassed the victim, but unfortunately
escalated to murder. I also heard the asalent is a nephew to
a high-ranking official in the Westfield Police Department and
that his father was also a cop and that the car used in the murder
was registered to a cop. This is information for people I from
people I trust, so take it as it is. But no matter what, this
is just a terrible incident and I pray for the victims and their
families. This Bobby
Uh, again, not sure how true. So, wow, this is horrible. Again,
not sure how true it is. I read it from a post in one of these.
So, this is just
kind of speculation. Did I watch McMad's video on Aerodite? Nope.
But, uh, we can check it out if you want to link it after we're
done this content piece
and go back over it. Okay. I'm sure it's funny. What it what
it is? Same one. same one. Okay. I'm just looking for more of
the um I'm looking for any other clips here. Lift up a video
harassing the mother and another uh the victim and her mother
for content. We watch that. He's talking about the girl being
afraid of him. He talks about his family uh getting the family's
private information to harass them. He talks about the accusations
he is facing. >> I'm still going to be here. I'm still
going to be living my life and you're just going to be a accuses
people of send an AI
about this whole thing. accusing people of rape and sending AI
porn. I think we watched this doomsday one as well. >> [__]
clown.
>> Jesus. Uh, I can't tell. Some of these look really similar,
so maybe we didn't >> You know, with this whole situation
that I'm going through, I'm not facing charges and cuz again,
>> all this stuff that has been proven already has been
a lie.
I talked to my school about what has happened and believe it
or not,
they're still making >> Oh, no. We just watched this one.
We literally just watched >> for a savory assessment. I
have absolutely no clue why. It's stupid. It's unnecessary. I've
shown no deviency and no violence.
And we've tried to appeal. >> Show no deviency and no violence.
Two months ago. Two months ago. This is like This is just free
free content. It's going to be massive content. Oh, am I seeing
what I think I see in the top right of my screen? Oh, you guys
can't see it. Hold on. I see some very interesting stuff. I see
a Rob's media response to YMS.
what did he say? I can't read. They want him to take a savory
assessment. A a structural What is it? Structural assessment
of violence risk in youth. Savory. They want him to take this.
And then he says, "I'm not violent. I'm not a deviant." So, it
looks like we got the new Rob's Media piece out as well. Now,
are we all done? I think I'm through most of the clips on this
guy.
And it's like psychotic. It's crazy. I don't think we watched
all of the mom speaking yet. Maybe I'll go back and check just
to see. Was that
No, that's him still. I don't even know if I God, I need to close
so many tabs. There we go. There it is. This was the uh the mom
speaking on this. We watch this and then we'll go over to the
Rob's media piece. Okay,
>> good evening everyone. First, I want to thank you all
for being here today, for showing up for Maria and for standing
beside me and my family during the hardest days of our lives.
Your love, your prayers, and your presence mean more than words
can say. My name is
I'm not standing here today just as a mother, but as Maria's
mother. And that is the greatest title I will ever hold. Maria
was 17 years old,
a high school senior, full of dreams, full of life, and full
of love. She wasn't just my daughter. She was my best friend,
my sunshine.
>> Did both girls die? Yes, both girls died. Both the girl
and her friend died. the kind of girl who could walk into a room
and light it up just by being herself. She had a laugh that could
soften the >> By the way, I just want to point out actually
that after
after watching the stuff from four months ago and two months
ago, I think it's 8 days ago. He talks about how eight days ago
and the stream the I think the stream right after he talks about
being bullied and the effect be like bullying had on him. We've
now come to realize that the bullying he's referring to is accusing
him of crimes that I feel like it seems likely he committed now,
right? Of like sending porn to this girl or stalking this girl,
harassing this girl. And he said he was being bullied.
And it's like, okay, I just I trust me or I don't know. Call
me crazy, all right? But I feel like there's every reason to
believe he did all of the things he's accused of when he essentially
goes like, I'm the victim and now I'm going to kill these people.
I don't know. Like it just it's wild that that now that we've
gone back through that timeline, we can see he's like talking
about oh well the the school wants me to take a risk assessment
for violence. The
uh like I'm there's apparently some legal case where where the
cops talk to the girl and she's crying about how scared she is
of him. And all of this amounted to what he calls later bullying
that he was bullied >> Hardest days
and a heart that cared deeply for everyone around her. Maria
had a passion for all things beautiful.
Music,
makeup,
hair,
fashion.
>> Yo, awesome sauce. Thank you for the five gifted. Let's
go. I happen to be looking at it right as it came through. So,
thank you very much for the five gifted.
Appreciate it. I have I have my notifications muted so they don't
interrupt the segments so much, but thank you very much. Thank
you. Thank you. No more donut sounds. I'm going to go and I'll
start going through the donations like after some period of time
like after each segment cuz I'm finding they just I spend like
if if it's like a busy stream we're getting donations I find
I spend like 20% I watch a YouTube video like 20% of time responding
to donations and stuff I I'm hoping that if I mute sometimes
I'll figure out a good system because I do want to incentivize
donation too but I like having the segments not get interrupted
>> but it wasn't just about appearances is
Maria believed in making people feel beautiful. When she talked
about her dream of becoming a makeup artist, it wasn't just about
glam. It was about helping people see the beauty in themselves
that maybe they had forgotten. She would practice for hours watching
tutorials, doing her friends makeup for fun, and always leaving
behind glitter, eye shadow palettes, and a whole lot of love.
She was going to graduate high school this year. She had plans,
big ones. She was going to attend cosmetology school, start her
own business one day. She had that sparkle, that ambition, that
fire. There are no words that can truly describe the pain of
losing your child. It's a silence that echoes louder than anything
I've ever heard.
It's waking up every morning wishing it was a nightmare, hoping
to hear that sweet, "I love you, Mom, Dad." It's an emptiness
in our home, in her room, in my arms.
But today, I choose not to speak only of grief. I choose to speak
of Maria's light. Her life may have been short,
but it was powerful. She loved deeply. She gave generously.
She dreamed boldly. And to >> Yeah,
it is obviously extremely sad. Tenstone. Yes. To Maria, my sweet
girl,
I will miss you every single day for the rest of my life. I will
picture your smile, hear your laugh in my heart, and carry your
dreams in my hand. You wanted to make the world more beautiful.
And my dark, you did just by being in it. You will never be forgotten.
You will always be loved. And I promise you, your light will
never go out. Thank you. Yes.
>> Oh, okay. Okay. Well, it's over for me. I don't know
if we got somebody who understands this. >> By the way,
another thing about um
one battle after another. That was something that happened was
there's just Spanish with no subtitles. I'm like, what the I
I'm not American. I can't speak Spanish. I can't I can't do it.
>> That's a good indication that a lot of the conservatives
are washing out of the chat. They don't like the politics content.
they don't like my political positions is that I just said something
incredibly triggering for conservatives and nobody even bothered
responding. You know,
you know, >> guys, I'm very sorry. Thank you so much for
coming and showing up for us. Thank >> Thank you. >> Spanish
is the official language of the USA, is it not?